what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some really
interesting and exciting news about the
future of the DCU James Gunn and DC have
revealed their future movies with what
they are calling chapter one and they've
revealed part of chapter one and a
second part of it is still yet to come
but what they have revealed for the
first part of chapter one is very
exciting and has a lot of fans talking
James Gunn and DC has revealed that we
are going to be seeing characters like
Superman Supergirl Batman and Robin and
the Green Lantern so some members of the
Justice League here so this has a lot of
people wondering when exactly are we
going to be getting an official Justice
League movie how is everything going to
build up to this movie which heroes are
going to be involved with this movie and
who is the villain going to be well
recently James Gunn might have told us
exactly who the villain is going to be
and kind of what the story arc for the
new Justice League film might be as well
recently Paul Shear posted to his
Instagram story he posted a picture of
DC's the New Frontier by Darwin Cook
with the caption on it after James
Gunn's big DC announcement something
tells me maybe it's a good time to
revisit this and what's interesting is
that James Gunn re-posted this to his
own story so many fans have begun to
wonder is this a hint at the Justice
League story and the villain that is to
come and a lot of fans right now think
yes and have already begun putting
together a lot of different Pieces Just
based off of the announcements that DC
has given us so far connecting projects
like Creature Commandos Swamp Thing and
of course lanterns and lanterns did give
us kind of a pretty big hint that the
center could be the villain so let's go
back real quick and listen to what James
Gunn had to say okay the next thing is a
big Premier HBO television series called
lanterns this is a story of a couple of
Green Lanterns Jon Stewart and Hal
Jordan and we have a few other lanterns
peppered in there but this is really a
terrestrial based TV show which is
almost like True Detective with a couple
of Green Lanterns who are space cops
watching over Precinct Earth in it they
discover a terrifying mystery that ties
into our largest story of the DCU so in
this he explains that how Jordan and Jon
Stewart and some other lanterns are
going to be the main characters they are
essentially kind of watching over Earth
and they discover a terrifying mystery
and here's the important part he says
that it ties into their larger story of
the DC Universe So based off of James
gunz's tease people are thinking that
this terrifying mystery could be the
center the center is an ancient mystery
with it pre-dating human existence the
center was born on a primordial Earth
millions of years before dinosaurs but
as it lived and as it existed on Earth
it watched all of this new life appear
and grow and over millions and millions
of years eventually it got to the age of
the dinosaurs then the asteroid came and
wiped out all of prehistoric life
however there was life that did survive
and it quickly relocated them to the
Pacific Ocean and it Formed itself as an
island to support all of the creatures
that survived and yes you heard me right
for those of you who may not know or may
not be familiar with the story the
center this Bean did form itself as an
island now eons went by and eventually
the center witnessed a new life form
emerge humankind and while it was fine
at first the center watching Humanity
eventually the center found Humanity to
be violent then in the 20th century it
saw them use the hydrogen bomb it saw
the mass destruction that it did and
eventually decided that humankind posed
a threat to the center's world and the
center decided that it was time for it
to leave the planet Earth but before it
did it was going to wipe out all of
humanity that's right kill all of its
humans so it starts to send flying
dinosaurs everywhere throughout the
Earth so it can get fuel so they could
bring it back and it could prepare to
leave now eventually it discovered jet
fuel at Cape Canaveral where the
spaceships launch and it decided that it
was time to let the world know of its
existence yes the humans were aware of a
Dinosaur Island but they didn't know
what it actually was an entity that is
the center and what they didn't know is
that it could have an influence on
people's mind it could subject them to
Madness and even violence so it goes to
Cape Canaveral and this is where all of
the heroes have to come together to
fight it but not without a big fight it
actually defeats Superman and many of
the heroes believe Superman to be dead
however they eventually defeat it with
the help of Hal Jordan aka the Green
Lantern who just became the Green
Lantern in the storyline he defeats it
by throwing it into space where it
explodes and they eventually find out
that Superman is alive then at the end
of this comic run the Justice League of
America is formed so how will this tie
into the new Justice League movie well
I'll tell you but before we dive into
that many of you have commented on my
new studio I just just wanted to say
thank you and a big shout out to my
partners over at Elgato they have
changed my convenience of work
drastically they've made it a lot easier
to get work done and they've made my
studio look a million times better from
all of the studio lighting that does not
make my room hot that you can control
with your phone or a stream deck to the
microphone that I literally use in each
video that I record if you are a Creator
a podcaster a gamer or if you're
thinking about getting into any of those
Elgato has the best equipment in the
business and if you're interested you
can check out my link in the description
and in the comments down below for my
Elgato gear now it seems like this is
kind of going to be like what we saw
with the Avengers DC is going to
introduce individual characters and then
there's going to be a big common threat
to the Earth that unites them and it
certainly seems like the center could
definitely be that big threat that big
bad that does that so they come together
in the Justice League film and from that
film on they are the this league however
it does seem like this story is going to
have to be changed in a few different
ways for starters the story in the
comics takes place in the 1940s and the
1950s now we're not really sure when the
DC universe's stories are going to take
place in time they could very well be
set in the 40s and the 50s but if
they're going to do a modern take on
them then this time frame is obviously
going to have to be changed which I
personally hope that they do I hope it
takes place during our time another big
thing that is going to have to change is
how Jordan's Green Lantern origin story
in the new frontier in the New Frontier
storyline how Jordan starts off not as
the Green Lantern but then he becomes
the Green Lantern towards the end of the
story as abhin Sir dies and he declares
him to be the new Green Lantern since
the lanterns are coming out before the
Justice League movie obviously that is
going to be different Hal Jordan will
already be a Green Lantern along with
Jon Stewart and some others however one
thing that I hope they do not change
about this story arc is that at this
time vigilante heroes are kind of
outlawed in fact during the story only
Superman and Wonder Woman are sanctioned
to be heroes by the government and are
allowed to be heroes so some heroes in
this story go into retirement like The
Flash and some just keep doing what they
do just avoiding the cops like Batman I
hope that they adapt this I think this
would be a pretty cool storyline and
eventually of course the ones that
retired come out of retirement to help
fight the center at the end and like I
mentioned the result at the end of that
is the formation of the Justice League
now the terrifying mystery that the
lanterns could be finding in the lantern
show is the center having that mental
influence on people causing them to go
mad causing them to kill themselves and
causing them to commit violence and
something that further connects the New
Frontier Justice League storyline with
the Green Lantern is that originally up
and Sir came to Earth on a mission of
great importance which was highly
suggested to be about the investigation
of the center and like James Gunn
mentioned the lanterns is kind of going
to be an investigative show perhaps
that's why why they are at Earth they
are there to investigate the center and
the effects that it is having on the
population of Earth now of course at
first they most likely won't know what
it is because it will probably be
disguised much like in the comics but if
they follow true to the comics somewhat
eventually this is what is going to
unite the Justice League and eventually
this is probably going to be that big
bad which is quite a different story
than we got with the previous Justice
League from the DC EU which is probably
what James Gunn is going to go for
something different something fresh and
this certainly is different and fresh
but do you like this idea if this is
indeed going to happen let us know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below do you like it do you hate it let
us know don't forget to like the video
and subscribe to stay up to date on the
latest DCU news of course you can follow
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof